how do you manage your chil uh realizing
we're all gonna die someday
well that stresses me out in the past
week you worried about the distant
future
that's just vague enough to cause me to
worry in the past week you're worried
about whether you made a stranger angry
it's like I don't go about much drink
yeah I'm sure I made a stranger angry
but I'm not worried about it
oh do you worry about your credit being
stolen or your identity being stolen I
mean as long as you check your credit
card bill every month you're okay right
probably not do you have fake arguments
in your head all the time okay okay I
like to plan out exactly what I would
say uh you've made someone call you when
they got home from visiting you to make
sure they got home okay
yeah that's just basic safety you're not
afraid to poop in the public restroom
what like you make a really loud fart
then someone's gonna go like whoa I'm
gonna remember your shoes so that I
could make funnier later literally I
called my mom this morning to try and
plan Thanksgiving vacation it's July
flights get expensive real fast can we
just compare our front pages real fast
this is my front page wanna mark
something that's hey you've called
someone and immediately followed up with
text who hasn't mom pick up my phone
calls I like how the last question says
you're worried you'll get a high score
on this quiz I definitely check that off
I mean people I think get a lot of
anxiety and a lot of really stressed out
about what other people are thinking
about them as soon as you're not talking
to somebody face-to-face they're not
thinking about you at all anymore I tend
to reach out to people who I trust and I
like express my thoughts turn the
negative into a positive and don't get
stuck on the things you keep control I
think that's the biggest thing yes you
still got to be you and care and stress
out good stress about things be able to
as Taylor Swift said shake it off here's
one thing people say I take too long in
board games I also rarely lose think
about that for a second